the first steps in massively parallel
sequencing are to prepare the DNA it is
broken into fragments that are 200 to
600 base pairs long an adenine a base is
then added to the 3 prime end of each
fragment short sequences of DNA called
adapters are then attached to the end of
each fragment
the double strands of DNA are then
separated into single strands these
single strands of DNA are then washed
across a flow cell this is a small
plastic side with lots of small pieces
of DNA called primers attached the DNA
strands bind to the complementary
primers on the flow cell and any DNA
that doesn't attach is washed away DNA
bases and DNA polymerase enzymes are
added so that the complementary strand
of DNA is made the attached DNA
fragments are then used as templates to
make lots of copies by a process called
bridge amplification
the DNA strands bend over and attach to
the primers on the surface of the flow
cell creating a bridge the complementary
strand is made along the bridge this
process is repeated several times
resulting in millions of small clusters
of DNA the DNA is denatured leaving
clusters of single-stranded DNA
to start the sequencing process small
pieces of DNA called primers plus DNA
polymerase enzymes and fluorescently
labeled DNA bases are added the primers
are attached to the DNA being sequenced
the DNA polymerase enzyme then binds to
the DNA and adds a complementary
fluorescently labeled DNA base to the
template DNA these fluorescent bases are
reversible terminator bases which means
that once they are added no other bases
can be added afterwards each of the
terminator bases give off a different
color colored lasers pass over the flow
cell causing the fluorescently labeled
bases to glow this fluorescent glow is
then detected by a digital camera once
this color has been recorded the
fluorescent Terminator tag is removed
from the base allowing a new
fluorescently labeled Terminator base to
be added this process is repeated over
and over until about a hundred and
twenty DNA bases have been sequenced
this type of sequencing is called
massively parallel sequencing because
millions of clusters are sequenced and
imaged simultaneously
the DNA sequence of each cluster is
exported from the sequencing machine for
assembly and analysis